أكد البنتاغون في وقت متأخر من
ليلة الخميس أن الجيش الأمريكي نفذ
ضربة قتلت الجنرال قاسم
سليماني قائد
الحرس الثوري الإيراني ، وهي
منظمة ألقت الولايات المتحدة باللوم عليها
في مقتل عدة أشخاص في العراق
وزيادة عدد الهجمات ضد
الولايات المتحدة.  في الأسابيع والأشهر الأخيرة ، نفذ الجيش الأمريكي
هذه الضربة في
مطار بغداد الدولي ، وتم
تدمير مركبتين في الضربة بحسب
الجيش العراقي الأمريكي.  قائلاً إن سليماني
كان مستهدفًا على حد سواء لأنه كان متقدمًا
على منظمة إرهابية أجنبية مصنفة من قبل الولايات المتحدة
ولكن أيضًا لأنه كان
يخطط بنشاط لهجمات ضد
أفراد أمريكيين في المنطقة وكان
وراء هجوم صاروخي مؤخرًا من قبل
جماعة تعمل بالوكالة إيرانية أسفرت عن مقتل
مقاول أمريكي و
المظاهرات الأخيرة التي حاولت اختراق
المحيط الخارجي
للسفارة الأمريكية في بغداد
لنا  الجيش يصف هذا كثيرًا بأنه
عمل دفاعي تحدث وزير الدفاع
مارك إسبر إلى المراسلين قبل
أنباء الضربة وأخبرهم أن
اللعبة قد تغيرت فيما يتعلق بإيران
ووكلائها وأن الولايات المتحدة
ستتصرف بشكل استباقي للدفاع عن
أرواح الأمريكيين ومصالحهم  في المنطقة ، هذه
الضربة مثال كبير على ذلك الآن
، وقد أمر الرئيس ترامب بالفعل بإرسال
قوات عسكرية أمريكية إضافية إلى
المنطقة في أعقاب الأحداث
التي شملت السفارة والهجمات الصاروخية ،
تم إرسال حوالي 100 من مشاة البحرية
إلى السفارة مئات من
المظليين الآخرين.  تم نشرهم في الكويت
للرد في حالة حدوث أزمة ، لذا
يمكن استدعاء تلك القوات إذا
تصاعد هذا الوضع يعتقد الكثيرون أن
إيران سترد على الأرجح على هذا
الإجراء نظرًا لمكانة الجنرال سليماني
داخل الجيش الإيراني ، لكن الجميع
سيراقب ما سيحدث بعد ذلك في  هذه
المنطقة ولكن هذا ولكن
خطورة الوضع وهذا التطور
لا يمكن التقليل من ريا  ن براون
البنتاغون
[موسيقى]
السيد.  أشكرك السفير على وقتك
الليلة مع هذه التطورات المفاجئة من
الواضح أن العالم بأسره يركز على
هذه القصة عندما تنظر إلى ما
حدث هنا هل كان هذا إعلان
حرب في الواقع كان عملاً حربياً
من جانب الولايات المتحدة ضد
الشعب الإيراني ، بدأت الولايات المتحدة
حربًا اقتصادية ضد الشعب الإيراني
في مايو 2018 عندما
قرر الرئيس ترامب الانسحاب
من الاتفاق النووي ، وبدأ
سياسة الضغط الأقصى ضد
الإيرانيين ، مما وضع الكثير من
الضغوط الاقتصادية على إيران وقد فعلوا ذلك.  استمروا
حتى اليوم
الليلة الماضية فتحوا فصلاً جديدًا في
هجومهم على الإيرانيين من خلال
اغتيال الأسد لواحد من
أعز جنرالاتنا المحبوبين ليس فقط
في إيران ولكن أيضًا في دول
المنطقة ، وكان ذلك كما قلت
فصلاً جديدًا  يرقى إلى بدء
حرب ضد إيران ، لذلك عندما تقول
أن مبلغًا واحدًا هو الحرب عملًا من أعمال الحرب ، فإن الكلمات
التي استخدمتها لسفير الثأر الثاني
ريمي زعيم إيران اليوم قال أو
تعهد بالانتقام الشديد وكلماته الأخرى
كانت انتقاما قاسيا لما
يسميه المجرمين الذين ارتكبوا هذا
الهجوم الأمريكيين فماذا يعني ذلك
إذا كنت ستنتقم
من عمل حرب هو  أن
الحرب ، كما قلت ، قامت بالفعل
بفرز الحرب ضد إيران ليس فقط
الحرب الاقتصادية ولكن أيضًا شيء يتجاوز ذلك من خلال
الاغتيالات في غانا أو كبار الجنرالات
الذين يحزنهم الناس في
إيران وفي المنطقة ، لذلك لا يمكننا
إغلاق منطقتنا.  عيون على ما حدث
الليلة الماضية بالتأكيد سيكون هناك انتقام
هناك انتقام قاسي حقًا ستعمل إيران
بناءً على اختيارها الخاص
وأن الوقت هو المكان
وتقرر حقًا ذلك من خلال قيامك بذلك ، لذا
أريد أن أسألك عن ذلك لأنه عندما
حدث هذا  لم يقل الرئيس ترامب الليلة الماضية
أنه كان يستهدف
شخصًا آخر والجنرال سليم
وحدث أنه قال إنه هو
واستهدفناه وقمنا بقتله
ولم يكن هناك وكلاء  لم يكن هناك أي
عذر يجعله مملوكًا لها ، فسترد إيران
بنفس الطريقة التي
تستهدف بها إيران الولايات المتحدة.
ما يمكنني
قوله هو أنه من خلال استهداف أحد كبار
جنرالاتنا تأكيدًا لنا
الالتزامات الدولية باستخدام
الفضاء الأرضي لدولة مستقلة
العراق دولة ذات سيادة ثم
الرئيس ، أنا آسف أن رئيس
وزراء ذلك البلد قد أدان
عمله العدواني من قبل الولايات المتحدة.  أعني
أنهم يجب أن يتوقعوا أي
شيء نتيجة لهذا العدوان
، حيث تسود كثافة هادئة حيث أن
الموكب الصباحي وتبدد بغداد
المزاج يكون كئيبًا للغاية ، يبدو الأمر
كما لو أنه يخفي الغضب الذي يكمن
وراءه ولكن عندما تتحدث إلى أي شخص.
عدد هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين انتقلوا
بمجرد أن قالوا إنهم تمكنوا من
التغلب على صدمتهم الأولية ، كان الشعور الرئيسي
بأنهم كانوا رغبة في
الانتقام ولكن أيضًا الغضب من
الولايات المتحدة كاد أن يرى أنها حوادث
خارج الجمارك اليوم - إنها ليست
إيران فقط  التي تتعهد بالانتقام من ذلك -
وكلاء الفنون في العراق الذين
أثبتوا بالفعل قدرتهم على القتل
أثناء الاحتلال الذي قادته الولايات المتحدة للعراق
، كلهم جزء من قو
ت الحشد الشعبي المكونة في الغالب من
ليشيات شي
ية سابقة  - في القيادة قُتل مع
قاسم سليماني أمينيكا التجارة دانيال
خطر ميسول-ها شودراك أون تشانسون ما
سأكون مدينًا لي بنوع من صدمة آنا
هذه المرة  من المحتمل أن يكون الهجوم الأمريكي التاريخي
تحويليًا مثل
الإطاحة بصدام حسين ، وكيف ستُسحب
خريطة العراق الجديد
في دماء هؤلاء الشهداء ، من الصعب
العثور على أي شخص يدعم الولايات المتحدة.  في
بلد دفع لعقود من الزمان ثمنًا
باهظًا للسياسة الخارجية الأمريكية في
ساحة التحرير ببغداد حيث
يتظاهر المتظاهرون المناهضون للحكومة
منذ شهور ضد
قادتهم والتدخل الخارجي ، لا يوجد
حب كبير لإيران ، لكن الآن هناك القليل من الحب لإيران.
الولايات المتحدة
والقوات الأمريكية المتمركزة
هنا يتزايد الجدل حول من
يتحمل اللوم الأكبر عن إراقة الدماء في العراق ،
إيران أو الولايات المتحدة ، لكن هناك
اتفاق على نقطة واحدة يحتاج كلاهما للخروج
وقد فعلت وأنا أعني
أننا نسافر ولكن هذا  ليست جزءًا من
حسابات التفاضل والتكامل لإيران أو الولايات المتحدة ، فهذه
الدولة هي ساحة لتصفية الحسابات
أروى ديمون سي إن إن بغداد
[موسيقى]